so it's crazy because I think back to
the Interscope days and you had I
remember when new freezer first came out
there was not a lot of people are
getting Kendrick Lamar features in the
world yeah not a lot of people still not
a lot still not a lot of people not a
lot of people then not a lot of people
now very rare to get a kdot feature
especially I feel like he really gave
you one of them ones that's an iconic
record
talk me through that whole era get in
the Kendrick verse and was there ever a
point in time where you almost were on
TDE because there were some Rumblings of
that I feel like uh I did something
so when you initially went to Interscope
it was through Top Dog yeah so I don't
think a lot of people know that yeah
so when I when I met Kendricks like I
was recording my app in one room
Kendrick recording his album one room
and sister recording album another room
so it was like all recording everybody
was in the same building so it was easy
to just have him kind of walk over and
hear some [__]
um no at the time I didn't even know he
was recording in there I just came and
did my [__] close the door right and
then one day they came in they're like
yo Kendrick wants to hear like some new
records
and then I played a new freezer he's
like yeah I need that you know this one
but now I was waiting for the verse for
like a month because he was on the road
and doing shows and [__]
so I was like damn actually I need to
cancel first how'd you feel when you got
it when you heard it for the first time
um you know
big accomplishment you know for for real
because before that I never had like a
hit song right that was your first like
big single yeah so I got signed pretty
much off of so when I got signed I was
signed to 300 ENT and I'm assigned to QC
records right and then like so I have to
like buy my way out so I never had no
hit so it's hard to get a lot of money
from a label when you have no streams so
I had to I had to pay QC 500 000 and I
had to give 300 300 000. plus I had to
get paid myself so you can imagine I had
a big deal signing my first deal so you
get the deal from Interscope and out of
that money you had to pay off QC and 300
300 and I had to get paid and you had to
still take some money home for yourself
yeah because at the time I was signing
QC and and not asked Pizza like you know
I'm saying do my thing he's like I need
500 000. and at the time I didn't have
five thousand dollars right you know let
alone 500. so I went in my phone
and I called everybody from every label
every label that I had on my phone right
you know and
thank God I found one person
uh Manny Smith I shot the Manny he's
like yo come to the office
you know and then it's history and God
God did the rest shout out to I mean
thank you yeah they let you buy yourself
out at least and they you know they
believed in me when I first jumped off
the gate you know what I'm saying for
sure I mean a lot of people kind of
would equate you to be like the fourth
unofficial media early on in your career
because you're on so many of those early
records you know yeah like me and Amigo
were dropping a lot of tapes and [__]
before they signed to qc2 so it was just
like we just hustling and working trying
to get our music heard you feel me how
close were you from like actually
joining the group though
never never happened